hello everyone i hope you're all having
a wonderful sunday and if not
this game will surely improve it it was
played a few moments ago
in the european online club cup uh the
group c
round two uh between uh german
grandmaster alexander donchenko and
russian ground master maxi matlakov
and it's uh it's quite uh quite an
amazing game so without further ado
let's check it out and
well let's just enjoy it and then you
can go back to enjoying your sunday
now uh donchenko with the white pieces
opens with
c4 sorry about that we have c6 by
matlakov
uh going for sort of a karo khan setup
against the english
we have d4 d5 knight to f3 in knight to
f6 and we basically transpose into the
uh slav defense with e3 and now bishop
to f5
uh now just uh developing the light
square bishop preparing e6 to
set up all of these pawns on light
squares and then uh well
you you won't have to worry about
developing your light square bishop as
that's usually
kind of the problem in these uh queen
spawns openings for black
uh so knight to c3 continuing
development this is all very standard
stuff we have e6
and now that the bishop uh has been out
of the cage
now uh we play knight to h4 we attack it
and we claim that
black spend all of these moves uh and
he's going to be
uh uh left without his bishop so bishop
g6 and now bishop to e2 white can
capture this bishop at any point so
it's no rush we have knight beat to d7
and now
bishop to d2 nicely continuing
development we have bishop to d6 and now
even
g3 preparing to the castle
uh we have castles by black
interestingly now you can't go e5 here
even though you would want to play such
a nice central breakthrough because for
example captures captures and knight
here
uh you're you not have to react to this
because the bishop is undefended and
after you move the bishop
for example captures captures and then
bishop the c3u
really really improved why the position
of uh
white's pieces the knight and e5 is
under attack and uh white is getting uh
a lot of
excellent um counter play so maybe not
something to do right away and
but black will uh strive towards this uh
in the future so here we have just
castles instead of this and
now comes knight captures on g6 finally
eliminating this bishop
uh h captures end the queen to b3
putting pressure on the b7 pawn so rook
to b8
and now rook the d1 interestingly this
game has been reached before it was
played in 2010 between evgeny bharev and
vasily gagarin
in the moscow open championship or
rather in the russian open championship
that was played in moscow
with bharev winning this game but here
instead of c5 closing the position we
have rook to d1 like i mentioned
and it is already as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game
uh so let's see how uh uh how matlakkov
deals with this we have b5 now
uh immediately going after this c for
pawn you don't want to allow this
capture so c
captures on the 5c captures and now
white castles and black says okay this
is nothing to worry about i'm just going
to play a6
and my position is great here all my
position
pieces are very nicely placed i can get
my knights the e4 my other knight can
come to f6 i can also play knight to b6
to c4
uh i can develop the queen i can put my
rooks on the uh open c file so
a lot of interesting ideas for black
here so
queen to c2 white wants to switch the
queen over to d3
and rook the c8 now we have queen to d3
and knight to b6 trying to get this
knight to c4 which would be excellent so
white of course prevents this with b3
and now
queen to e7 developing the queen
connecting rooks and now
uh a4 trying to create some weaknesses
here on the queen side but black doesn't
allow it just b4 pushes the knight back
and then he's gonna cement the position
with a5
so knight to the a2 with a5 uh and
now queen to a6 and queen to a6 is a
very interesting
uh but maybe a bit a bit safer with rook
to c1
uh black already has control of the c
file so you usually want to counter that
but okay here we have queen to a6 and
now
rook the c2 and here black is saying
okay
we can trade pieces but the problem is
if we trade pieces i will already
have a rook on the second rank and it's
going to be a just a just a monster
so here knight to c1 now keeping this
knight here as a target
and now knight the e for black again
offers this because
well the the bishop on d2 is attacked
twice
so here white should go bishop to d3 and
kind of try and force black to deal with
this uh rook and the knight so either
capture the bishop or move the rook or
something
but here we have bishop to e1 by
dunchenko and
now comes queen to c7 and this move not
only defends the knight here but also
puts pressure on this knight because now
this knight is under attack
twice and uh well what
what do you do here there's simply too
much too much pressure here
one thing you could do is f3 f3 is a
very interesting idea because now
the knight obviously has to move in for
example after knight to c3 we could see
captures captures
and now the game continues from this
position where black would enjoy a very
very strong pass pawn here
most likely it would be winning for
black so instead after queen to c7 we
have queen captures on a5 by donchenko
and now comes rook to b8 uh so again
what do you play here uh here again f3
is always an idea uh but now comes
bishop captures on b4 instead
grabbing yet another pawn uh now comes
bishop captures on b4 and now queen
captures on b4 and now
knight to c3 so what do you play here
uh it's hard to say the rook is under
attack but uh you know it's not
easy to to deal with this because if you
try something like rook to e1
then you just get rook captures on c1
removing the defender of the bishop on
e2 and if captures it then we just get
this captures with check
king g2 and not just knight captures on
c1 there's nothing to be played here if
characters then captures i mean black is
just up so much material
so instead after knight to c3 we have
bishop to d3
now putting pressure on the rook here
but now just knight
captures on d1 we have bishop captures
on c2
queen captures on c2 and now queen to c5
offering a queen trade and this
definitely makes sense because if for
example queens are traded
then this knight is hanging and this
knight is hanging so it doesn't really
matter what you do white will
uh grab back the the the extra knight
and the
white will enjoy some some past pawns
here but all in all the position should
be
equal so instead after queen to c5 we
have queen to d2
uh black avoids this and now comes queen
to c7 putting pressure on the rook and
of course if the rook moves then
uh the knight will fall but now uh white
missed a very very strong reply here
from black so feel free to pause the
video
and this is only the first moment uh
we're pausing the video in
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
and try to find the only winning move
for black while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
giving back some material uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
rook the c8 now you see what's happening
the queen is under attack you give up
the knight on b6
and after queen captures on b6 now you
most certainly do not capture the knight
because if you capture the knight then
you run into a perpetual queen d8
checking h7 and queen to h for check
with uh
constantly going back and forth queen to
d8 to check queen to h4
check and we're gonna have a uh draw by
perpetual check so instead
after sacrificing here you play king to
h7
first and now again what do you play
here
uh the only good move for white is queen
to b7 this is the only thing that makes
uh some sort of sense for white to
continue because it attacks the rook
into the f7 pawn and after rook the c2
with a triple attack on the f2 pawn now
you play queen captures here
now you're defending it twice with the
queen and the rook but now
knight captures on e3 making it
impossible for white to capture because
of this checkmate but now you're gonna
play knight
to d3 and now uh you know it's a very
very
uh uh tricky position if you capture
this knight then f captures on e3
becomes possible
and if you don't if you play knight
captures on f1 then knight the e5 and
now white ensures a perpetual here
with queen captures on g6 and queen to
e8 to check
or you could go back queen to g5 but
then just king captures on f1
and all in all this uh this should be a
draw black is up the exchange but white
has two connected past pawns so
white has all the control play needed uh
and the black does not have a forced win
so uh instead after king to h7 we don't
have that we actually have
knight to a2 white says all right you
can capture my knight here and i'm just
going to capture this knight here but
such a thing
did not happen here black played knight
captures on e3
uh now what's the idea here well if pawn
captures then just rook to c2 with an
unstoppable checkmate
so instead after knight captures on e3
white goes for queen to b7
now attacking the rook here but now rook
to c2 and okay it's not a problem
y just says okay now i can get my knight
to the safety tonight the b4 was played
but here there is one one amazing move
that black played
so feel free to pause the video here and
win the game on the spot for black while
i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on playing
any of the moves that win there are many
moves that win here but
for those of you who found the absolute
uh killer move uh then
truly congratulations especially if you
found both this move and
the previous move uh and that move is of
course
queen captures on f2 and after queen
captures an f2 check was played it was
in this position on move 33 that
alexander dunchenko resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
this is just over
uh there is no move you can play here if
king h1
of course queen captures on f1 is
checkmate and if what
you were wondering what if the queen is
captured well if the queen is captured
notice how the knight
covers these two squares and that that's
a problem now because now
rook to c1 check uh there's nowhere for
you to go these two squares are covered
you have to block with the rook
rook to f1 would be played and now rook
captures on f1 would be checkmate the
knight still covers the
the g2 square and the these two squares
are covered by the rook
the rook is also nicely protected by the
knight so
that's just it uh amazing amazing game
uh with a lot of
uh with a lot of possibilities it could
have gone either way but after this
knight to be for mover
white said all right i'm getting my
knight back into the game black said no
nope and that's it queen captures an f2
we can check it out uh
once more in slow motion like this queen
captures on f2 and that was it
so really really amazing stuff a
beautiful uh beautiful move in the game
to you know commemorate this nice sunday
uh so hope you guys enjoyed that as well
uh i would like to thank paul jacobs uh
will lesbian
larsen sposky 1970 joseph brought and uh
j.g mockler for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check uh two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day